I think transparency is really important
for the healthy functioning of democracy
is absolutely right that there's
disclosures around donations and outside
interests and transparency is a good
thing and I fully support it was it
right that six two of the sons are being
given to MPS I think transparency is
really important and that's why we have
a set of rules and regulations in place
to provide that transparency for people
and it's important that those rules are
adhere to
the Prime Minister speaking uh in the
last hour joining me now our political
correspondent Ali fortiscu who is in
Leeds with the Prime Minister uh Ali
it's interesting isn't it that uh the
Prime Minister obviously accepts that
transparency is very important but it's
journalists who have provided this tool
rather than Parliament
yeah that's right so this data was
always available but it was incredibly
hard to get hold of so what we've done
is bring it all together and this is the
first time the Prime Minister has been
asked about this you heard him there
saying twice that transparency is
important that's something that he backs
but on the specifics about mysterious
companies donating money to MPS he was
he was less clear and of course the big
Revelations yesterday were all about
second jobs outside earning 17 million
pounds worth of outside earning 15
million that goes to conservative MPS
the top three of course Theresa May
Jeffrey Cox and Boris Johnson all
conservatives he didn't really want to
comment on the specifics this morning
the Prime Minister though was key to
stress that he thinks transparency is
important which I think is a message
echoed by many MPS privately whether or
not they're particularly happy about the
lid that we've lifted on the way that
money flows through Westminster I think
that's clear
Ali you also asked the Prime Minister
about the NHS strikes
yeah I did and
I think he was absolutely determined not
to deviate from his Central message I
worth saying we are in Leeds in West
Yorkshire he was visiting this
Healthcare Center talking about the
government's plans to bulk by Care Home
Bears to try to move people on to spare
some space in hospitals what he was
determined to talk about when it came to
strikes was the fact that government
have invited unions in for talks today I
think what we have seen I think it's
fair to say is a shift in tone a shift
in rhetoric he's saying that the
government are happy to talk about pay
but the big question is obviously the
details the specifics because there's
been confusion about whether the
government are talking about pay for
2022-23 it looks like that's not the
case that's obviously what unions want
to see and what we understand is still
on the table is the idea of a one-off
payment for nurses that could help to
unlock the deadlock perhaps bring the
two sides together on that I asked him
about that twice and again he was very
keen to talk about the important talks
that are happening but he did not want
to be dragged into the detail he didn't
rule it out there have a listen to this
I'm really pleased that union leaders
accepted Minister's invitations to come
in today to have discussions across the
board and that's a really positive
development and on pay we've always said
that the government is happy to talk
about it paid demands and pay issues
that are anchored in what's reasonable
what's responsible what's affordable for
the country but the most important thing
is those talks are happening and let's
try and sit down and find a way through
so to confirm a one-off payment is on
the table you wouldn't you wouldn't
expect me to comment on specifics but
the most important thing is that the
conversations are happening that people
are talking and with regard to pay we
have to have those conversations based
on what is Affordable what's reasonable
what's responsible for the country but
look people need to get talking that's
what they're doing and hopefully we can
find a way through this